(applaudissements)
- Louise Portal, pour vos 50 ans
de crererere, vous recevez
tout un cadeau, c'est le prix
Iris du Gala Québec Cinéma.
Alors, comment vous vivez
ndndndnd moment-là?
LOUISE PORTAL, actrice, auteure,
chanteuse et romancière
- Avec beaucoup de gratitude,ide
une étape, hein, je me retire
doucement sur la pointe des
pieds quand même, après 50 ansd.
C'est que ça permet de faire
un bilan puis de regarder
en arrière. Puis la tout à coup,
je reçois ce qu'il va y avoir
dans le programme et je vois:
"ah oui, tel film," "ah mon
Dieu, j'avais oublié que j'avais
fait tel film." "Ah, il y a ça,
il y a ça." C'est plein de
souvenirs qui remontent.
Des belles rencontres,
vraiment, des cadeaux,
souvent, des cadeaux.
- Vous parlez de souvenirs,
de bilan. Remontons dans
le temps justement, parce que
toute petite, avec vos soeurs,
vous faisiez des spectacles
dans le garage ou sur le toit
du garage. Votre père était
écrivain. Jusqu'à quel point et
vous avez d'ailleurs publier vos
correspondances avec votre père,
jusqu'àt t t t t t votre père
est responsable de Louise
Portal?
- Bien, j'ai le nom de plume
de mon père. Moi, je suis née
Lapointe. Et puis, Portal,
c'est le nom de plume que Papa
a choisi en 1960 pour publier
un premier livre. Et j'ai
compris, mais beaucoup plus
tard, qu'il avait une grande
influence dans ma vie.
Je lui ressemble beaucoup.
Je fais des cahiers, je fais
des collages. Papa était
comme ça. Il entretenait
des correspondances
avec beaucoup de monde.
Moi, j'ai eu beaucoup de
correspondants, j'ai écrit
beaucoup de lettres d'amour
dans ma vie. Je corresponds
avec ma grand-maman d'adoption,
qui a 101 ans maintenant.
Donc, j'ai beaucoup de traits
qui ressemblent à mon père.
♪ Si si do si la
sol fa la si la sol ♪
- Je veux parler d'un film qui
vous a marquée, "Cordélia" de
Jean Beaudin, où vous incarnez
une femme et son amant,
tous les deux jugés injustement.
Elle se retrouve en prison.
C'est une grande injustice.
C'est un film qui
vous a marquée?
- C'est sûr que "Cordélia"mememt
émouvant et tellement important
pour moi parce que "Cordélia"
c'est une histoire vraie.
i i i i i i i incarne
un personnage qui a eu une vie
qui a vraiment vibré pour
de vrai, c'est comme si
son âme ven
nous visiter pour qu'on puisse
lui donner une chance
de s'incarner à l'écran.
Alors, en plus, elle a e
destin tragique. J'étais super
bien entourée par une pléiade
de comédiens merveilleux et sous
la direction de Jean Beaudin.
Scénario écrit par Marcel
Sabourin et Jean. Écoute, c'est
comme quelque chose qui était à
mon avis, je le crois
profondément, était inscrit dans
mon destin. Puis, regarde, son
nom: Cordélia, une corde. Elle
était liée à une corde, puis
elle va mourir pendue. C'est pas
rien. Je pourrais faire toute
une entrevue là-dessus.
(rires)
- Sylvie, Nathalie, Julie,
Sophie.
- Parlons de votre 10e film,
et j'ai nommé... "Le déclin
de l'empire américain".
- Ah! mon Dieu!
- Votre personnage de Diane,
ça vous a ouvert les portes
à l'international...
- Oui.
- ... vraiment! De quelle façon?
- Bien écouté, c'est un film qui
a fait le tour du monde. Alors
moi ça été mon passeport.
(musique classique)
Ils sont venus me chercher. f .
Mais je ne me serais pas vue
faire une carrière
internationale ou même
FrFrFrFrFrFrFrFrFrFrance.
Ça a passé proche, là!
C'est sûr qu'en 82, quand
je tourne "Les Fauves",
je fais la
de Maxime Le Forestier à Bobino.
Mais l'exil n'était pas
pour moi, il faut croire,
puis je regrette rien
parce que là où je suis
maintenant, aujourd'hui,
c'est exactement la place
où je suis heureuse d'être.
Dans ma vie professionnelle
et ma vie personnelle.
- En préparant cet entretien,
ce qui me fascinait, c'est
que vous êtes vraiment
une artiste multiforme.
Télévision, cinéma, des livres,
de la musique aussi. Vraiment,ts
choses qui vous fascinent
dans la vie, là. Vous dévorez
la vie carrément.
- Oui.
- Alors, comment
vous voyez ça, justement,
vieillir, Louise Portal?
- J'aime mieux parler d'abord
du vieillir. Parce que pour moi
ce n'est pas la même chose que
vieillesse. Vieillesse est
entachée de beaucoup de...
- De sig
- Oui, préjugés... Le vieillir,
c'est accepter qu'on est,
qu'on a tous ce bagage et
puis qu'on continue d'avancer.
Comme moi, je comprends pas ça,
là, les actrices... qu'il faut
qu'elles se fassent refaire,
puis qui... qui refusent de
vieillir. Je comprends pas ça.
- Ah non?
- Parce que pour moi, être
une actrice, c
c'est se mettre au service...
d'une incarnation, dans le fond,
de prêter tout son être
à une incarnation, son coeur,
son âme, sa sensibilité,
ses défauts, ses qualités.
Puis, on est chanceuses,
parce que si tu fais pas ça
dans la création, tu risques
de le faire dans la vie,
puis des fois, c'est pas drôle.
(rires)ueueueueueueueueueueueuee
reconnaisses pas.
- Louise Portal, merci
pour cette belle rencontre.
- Bienvenue.